much of your passions and life has been
through something you might be able to
call work Alan Watts has this quote he
said that the real key to life secret of
life is to be completely engaged with
what you're doing in the here and now
and instead of calling it work realize
that it's play so I'd like to ask what
is the role of work in your life's
journey or in a life's journey and what
do you think about this modern idea of
kind of separating work and let
work-life balance I have a principle
that I believe in is make your work in
your passion the same thing okay okay so
that's similar face
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh in other words if you can
make your work in your passion it's just
gonna work out great and then of course
people have different purposes of work
and I don't want to be theoretical about
that people have to take care of their
family so money at a certain point is
the base is an important component of
that work so you look beyond that what
is money gonna get you and what are
you're trying to achieve but the most
important thing I agree is meaningful
work and meaningful relationships like
if you can get into the thing that your
your mission that you're on and you are
excited about that mission that you're
on and then you can do that with people
who you have the meaningful
relationships with you have meaningful
work and meaningful relationships I mean
that is fabulous for most people and it
seems that many people struggle to get
there not out of not necessarily because
they're constrained by the fact that
they have the financial constraints of
having to provide for their family and
so on but it's I mean moat you know this
idea is out there that there needs to be
a work-life balance which means that
most people on this thing we're gonna
return to the same things most doesn't
mean optimal but most people seem to not
be doing their life's passion not be not
unifying work and passion why do you
think that is is
while the work-life balance there's a
life arc that you go through starts at
zero and ends somewhere in the vicinity
of 80 and there is a phase and there's a
and you could look at the different
degrees of happiness that happened in
those phases I can go through that if
that was interesting but we don't have
time probably for it but you get in the
part of the life that part of the life
which has the lowest level of happiness
is aged 45 to 55 and and and because as
you move into this second phase of your
life in the first phase of your life is
when you're learning dependent on others
second phase of your life is when you're
working and others are dependent on you
and you're trying to be successful and
in that phase of one's life you
encounter the work-life balance
challenge because you're trying to be
successful at work and successful at
parenting and successful and successful
in all those the things that take your
demand and they get into that and I
understand that problem in the work-life
balance the issue is primarily to know
how to approach that okay so I I
understand it's stressful it produces
stress and it produces bad results and
it produces the lowest level of
happiness in one's life it's interesting
as you get later in life the levels of
happiness rise in the highest level of
happiness is between ages 70 and 80
which is interesting there are other
reasons but in an apt spot I want an net
and the key to work-life balance is to
realize and to learn how to get more out
of an hour of life okay because an hour
of work what people are thinking is that
they have to make a choice between one
thing and another and of course they
they do but they don't realize that if
they develop the skill to get a lot more
out of an hour it's the equivalent of
having many more hours in your life and
so you know that's why in the book
principles I try to go into okay now how
can you get a lot
more out of out of an hour that allows
you to get more life into your life and
it reduces the work/life balance and
that's the primary struggle in that 35
to 45 you know if you could linger on
that sort of what are the ups and downs
of life in terms of happiness in general
and perhaps in your own life when you
look back at the moments the peaks it's
pretty pretty much same pattern Roley in
one's life is tends to be a very happy
period all the way up and 16 is like a
really great happy you know I think like
myself you start to get elements of
freedom you get your driver's license
you know whatever but 16 is their junior
year in high school quite often could be
a stressful period to try to get think
about the high school you go into
college tends to be very high and
Happiness generally speaking freedom and
then freedom yeah friendships all of
that freedom is a big thing and then you
and then 20 23 is a peak point kind of
an unhappy 'no staff freedom then
sequentially one has a great time they
date they go out and so on you find the
love of your life you begin to develop a
family and then with that as time
happens you have more of your work-life
balance challenges that come and your
responsibilities and then as you get
there in that mid part of your life that
is the most that is the biggest struggle
chances are you will crash in that
period of time you know you'll have
you'll have your series of failures
that's the that's that that's when you
go into the abyss you learn you
hopefully learn from those mistakes you
have to metamorphosis you come out you
change hopefully become better and you
take more responsibilities and so on and
then when you get to the later part as
you are starting to approach the
transition in that late part of the
second phase of your life before you go
into the third phase of your life second
phase is you're working trying to be
successful the
third phase of your life is you want
people to be successful without you okay
yes yeah you want your kids to be
successful without you because when
you're at that phase they're at making
their transition from the first phase to
the second phase and they're trying to
be successful you want them to be
successful without you and you have and
your parents are gone and then you have
freedom and then you have freedom again
and that with that freedom and then you
have these histories shown with this you
have friendships you have perspective on
life you have different things and
that's one of the reasons that that
later part of the life can be real it on
average actually it's the highest very
interesting thing if they yet and they
their surveys and say how good do you
look and how good do you feel and and
that's the highest serving the person
now they not look in the best yeah and
they're not feeling the best right maybe
it's 35 that they're actually looking
the best and feeling the best but they
rank the highest at that point survey
results of being the highest so that 70
to 80 period of time because it has to
do with an attitude on life then you
start to have grandkids old grandkids
are great and you start to experience
that transition well so that's what the
arc of life pretty much looks like and
and I'm experiencing it you know that's
good
you